Tom what is desantis's Camp thinking
about right now what is Biden's Camp
thinking about right now what are Dems
thinking about right now what are
Republicans thinking about right now
what I mean by Republicans Tom I'm
talking to Camp you know McConnell
I'm talking about you know uh uh the the
folks that are not necessarily a trump
Republican the Rhinos right so DeSantis
okay Biden's Camp Trump's Camp
Republicans and Demps what are they
thinking I'll take a couple maybe Adam
will take a couple uh I'm gonna take
McConnell and I don't think McConnell's
happy McConnell is a good legislator I
think when he sees this indictment any
any lawyer or person who's going to look
at this and they're going to think about
the the Clinton campaign finance and
he's gonna be sitting there thinking
man you know this is weak and they're
really getting this guy revved up so I
don't think McConnell is going to be
very enthusiastic about this at all uh
the core the RNC I don't think the RNC
is happy at all I think they've seen the
opposition research they see things come
out I think they're scrambling a little
bit I don't think they're happy
um I think that
I'll go to someone like Chuck Schumer I
think Chuck Schumer is going to put on a
brave face in public Pat but I think
behind closed doors Chuck Schumer is
Raising eyebrows and and and maybe he
looks a little bit like the emperor of
Japan I fear we have awakened a sleeping
giant because Schumer is smart and he's
known Trump for a long time and
Schumer's a street fighter and he knows
a street fighter when he sees him and I
believe that Chuck Schumer is sitting
there I fear we have awakened a sleeping
giant sauce
I'm just thinking if I'm the Biden Camp
I'm just reading the Art of War by Sun
Tzu and what's the famous quote when
your enemy is out of this way just get
out of his way just don't even say
anything if you're Joe Biden right now
you just kind of let this circus play
out because this is a circus and you
know I I for me this is a very sad day
for America because I was generally
waiting until 2024 until the nonsense
of political season basically kicked off
but this is the kickoff of political
nonsense season so uh more than anybody
I'm sure there are a lot of people on
the left that are celebrating this I
watched Stephen Colbert the other day
and you're talking about someone who
used to be when he was doing The Colbert
Report and Daily Show just such an
awesome just
instinctual comedian at this point like
the you know to be a great comedian you
need to basically have the art of
surprise but there's no surprise at this
point he basically when they this was
what Friday the news came out that the
indictment was coming out you know he
says all right guys you know Trump got
indicted The Crowd Goes Wild
and for me that's a sad situation
because more than anything uh I care
about America what do you think our
enemies like our actual enemies are
doing right now when China is looking at
us right now when Russia is looking at
us right now when Iran is looking at us
now you're saying this is what you stand
for America this nonsense right here and
it's just saddening to me because our
enemies are basically looking and being
like this [__] circus of a country is
just getting worse and worse and worse
and that's what they want and I do agree
that no one is above the law but I also
agree that nobody should be targeted by
the law right and I think that's what a
lot of people think is happening right
here because this is about
hush money payment to a porn star okay
this there can be arguments made because
correct me if I'm wrong this isn't the
end of the Investigation season of trump
they're going to be investigating him
still for January 6th they're still
investing them for that phone call he
made to Georgia find me 10 000 votes
there's gonna be more to come and the
fact that this is where we're at in this
country is that the president has been
arrested and charged for hush money to a
porn star and they're using all sorts of
legalese and everyone's going to give
their million different opinions but at
the end of the day Donald Trump has been
arrested for his interactions with a
porn star you know you know it's wild
while all of this is going on we're
having a live podcast on Thursday with
Giuliani and Reuben yeah if there's
anybody qualified enough to talk about
what's going on with this for that
Thursday night podcast that was we're
having it's going to be uh Rudy because
he's gone through this mess so many
times the last 50 60 years but to me you
know while you see something like this
is is are Republicans sitting here
saying the following the Republican
voter the Republican voter saying man
shoot okay so let's just say we get
Trump
even if Trump gets only four years he's
not going to get eight years to create
momentum he's going to get four years
and after his four years would Trump be
willing to help the Santas get eight
years so for it to be 12 years because
the Santa is going to end up being a
president 70 80 Chance is going to be a
president so this time four years eight
years nobody knows but
is he willing to do that and if he does
are they going to let him do what he
needs to do in four years or is it going
to be like this every day every day
Trump tries to pass a bill a law
whatever whatever every day they're
gonna say do you know this came up you
know that came up and the Republican the
average Republican voter is saying dude
do I really want to mess with this for
another four years then the Maga voters
say no this is exactly the guy that's
going to get the job done who else do
you want to put in there okay the moment
they're done getting rid of him they're
going to Target the Santa's next so
whether you like it or not they're going
to Target anybody that's on the right
side this is the right guy to come and
get the job now for you as a voter how
do you process this as a voter you're a
guy that's a policy guy okay you're not
a guy that's like you're more about who
can get the policies down and get the
job done how does this get you to be
concerned about whether any of the
policies that need to be get done will
will he be able to do that in that
four-year period
well yes I'm a policy guy and
on one hand but over the last two weeks
as this has been slowly you know coming
to a boil and I've been you know I don't
just look at certain media and get
myself revved up because I'm only
looking at NBC and you know you know 80
of that goes one way and it frustrates
me I'm looking at this now saying you
know what
this country needs to fight and we need
to fight back and against what we want
to slowly becoming this this standard
and you don't do that mildly you don't
do that with policies you you have to do
that very deliberately and very strongly
um and we saw it happen with the tea
party we saw it happen with um Reagan go
back and take a look at at this country
the Reagan Carter uh election didn't
have the internet didn't have all that
but there is a lot of tension there was
a lot of stuff going on and it took a
strong force to come back and drive it
and so yeah policy people may work in a
bipartisan way but Pat that's only when
Congress is functioning as a bipartisan
Cooperative Congress
if they're not then you need you need
this strength you need to draw the line
you need to hold the line and you know
it's the uh
it's it's a new world we live in and I
am a very
you know
pissed off voter right now with what I'm
saying I'm I'm angered to action not to
Revenge but I'm angered to action really
forcefully I'm not going to go lightly
with friends and family that I talk to
I'm going to be very logical as I'm
going to be Tom but I'm going to be
pretty direct with them about what what
are you standing for this is not a man
be pamby
time this is you got to say this is your
country this is what you want you you
want to be like the Brits who have Prime
Ministers for 10 minutes we've seen that
three prime ministers in the last what
18 months and over what we didn't like
Breck said and Boris is a drunk okay
three two one and a votes out you want
that you want a revolving door or you
want to you want leadership and people
get [__] done excuse me
that's where I'm at right now
you know shit's real when Thomas cursing
yeah exactly I think you hit the nail on
the head is that like looking ahead you
know what do the next four years look
like with Trump and one can argue that
it's going to be even uglier on both
sides after all this plays out because
you know Trump's famous for saying you
know if you come at me I'm gonna come at
you a hundred times harder right so
let's say he's acquitted from this right
so let's go best case scenario for Trump
he's acquitted
do you know how vindictive and ugly he
could rightfully get you tried to do
Russia with me you tried to do Ukraine
you tried to do this you tried to do
that then you [__] tried to throw me
in jail do you know how ugly and
vindictive it can get and for the
country you know and then the media is
going to come after him double down on
everything like I didn't think things
could get even uglier than they did in
2016 2018 2020
and I feel like 2024 is basically like
yeah hold my beer buddy because we're
about to see how ugly things can get and
As Americans this is this is a sad day
because I think this is the the the
Tipping Point and the starting point for
when the ugliness round two round three
arguably is going to begin and and I
don't think anybody wants that um for
our country and the whole reason that
Joe Biden even got elected nobody was
out there rooting for Joe Biden it's
just they didn't want the Trump trained
circus that was continuing to basically
have a second term and Biden's proven to
be a Walking Corpse at this point you
know I think even dem's I think 60 of
Dems 55 of Dems don't want him to run
again whatever the number is today
um I don't know it's just that this is
not a good day for America if you hate
Donald Trump I get it I mean or if you
have trunk derangement syndrome I get it
but this is not a good look for the
country that you live in you know the
election we only now at eight to eleven
percent voted not Trump they didn't vote
for Biden they voted not Trump right and
it was the dissatisfied
you know on a scale of one to ten you're
five to sixes ten being liberal zero
being conservative the five to sixes on
that moderate middle eight to eleven
percent voted not Trump not for Biden
and Pat says this all the time there's
10 to 12 percent of the country that
controls the elect the country the swing
States the the Midwest the Rust Belt and
there's going to be polling like crazy
in those areas to see what they think
about this indictment and those are the
people that basically our country goes
so we'll see what they have to say about
this matter we all know that 40
something percent of the country love
Donald Trump and 40 something percent of
the country hates Donald Trump and
that's not changing so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you